[MUSIC]
Previously on Grit & Growth, we explored
the stories of two strategic acquisitions
in Africa involving Nigerian and
Ethiopian fin techs and
a Kenyan IT outsourcing company.
In both those episodes, we got
powerful insights from Victor Basta,
CEO of DAI Magister.
>> In a geography like
the African continent,
the multiplier value multiplication on
your own time of entrepreneurial effort,
you cannot get a greater multiplier
anywhere in the world today.
>> Victor is an expert in mergers and
acquisitions on the continent.
And today we're taking a deeper dive one
on one to discover more about what he's
learned along the way.
We discuss the quid pro quo of
working in frontier markets,
how to attract potential buyers,
how to get your own team on side and
how to maintain value throughout
the due diligence process.
[MUSIC]
I'm Darius Teeter and
this is a masterclass by Grit and
Growth with Stanford Graduate School
of Business, the show where Africa and
South Asia's intrepid entrepreneurs
share their trials and triumphs.
But enough from me,
let's let Victor introduce himself.
>> So, I'm Victor Basta,
I'm the CEO of DAI Magister.
And we're, at the moment, probably
the most active advisory firm handling
larger rounds and M&A deals for
companies in Africa and the Middle East,
growth companies really focused
on tech enabled businesses.
>> I read an interview that you did some
time ago, and then when there was this
great quote in there where you said, you
don't see yourself as somebody who does
the deals, but
someone who helps people through deals.
And you consider it a privilege to be
involved in somebody's transformational
life experience.
Can you say a bit more about that?
>> Sure, almost everything we do is at
a point where an enormous amount for
a company and a team is on the line.
And we get used to it after a while,
I've been doing this almost 30 years.
But one has to step back a little bit to
realize that pretty much everything we
work on is more than an inflection point,
more than a pivot point for a company.
I've lost count of the number of life
changing events I've been privileged
to have a ringside seat to.
But more than that, and this is where
really the privilege part comes in,
you're in the middle of helping create it.
So to be able to create other people's
life changing events over and over and
over again, it's the reason I'm willing
to get up and do conference calls at
7 o'clock in the morning on
a Saturday after all these years.
And it's a reason why we decided to pivot
so much of our work towards emerging
markets which are much harder to work in,
but the privilege is even greater.
>> So
can you say a little bit more about that?
What's happening in the African emerging
market ecosystem in the mergers and
acquisition space that's exciting or
interesting or new?
>> For the first time in history,
you have a group of companies
that are starting to transform
life on the continent in a way
that grant money never could.
And the process of industrialization
on a continent that
has far less infrastructure
than it needs to have and
will not be fixed for decades,
the only way to accelerate
industrialization is through
technology enabled businesses.
Of course, you need to build dams and
rivers and highways.
But again,
that in and of itself is not going to
transform economic life on the continent.
The only way to transform economic
life and therefore give ourselves
all a chance is accelerating the
industrialization successfully of Africa.
And the other dimension is that for
Africa to industrialize
successfully in this day and
age isn't the same way that China did it,
burn coal and basically scorch the earth.
We can't afford to do that.
[MUSIC]
>> Industrialization in Africa actually
might mean something completely different
which is the remote distribution
of digital services,
expansion of network penetration, lower
cost of band width, lower cost of devices,
which enables a whole bunch of things,
that never actually need to be brick and
mortar along the way, right?
So, getting back to how we bring
that capital into these sectors,
what does it look like
to do these types of
deals that would bring that kind of
growth capital in these markets?
>> That money is not available on
the continent for the most part,
with very few exceptions.
It's not local or regional or
continental money,
that money needs to be
attracted from abroad.
So doing these deals is all about
developing a degree of conviction from
the group of international investors
who could put their money anywhere,
do not have to put it into Africa.
And developing that conviction in
what still is considered a frontier
market means you have to overcome
a lot of initial objections.
One of the big things that we see
is that a fair amount of the money
raised is used effectively to,
quote, reinvent the wheel.
What I mean by that is that in Europe or
the US, you can rent infrastructure.
I mean, these days you can rent AWS and
rent everything and
you can literally get into business
tomorrow and deploy your product.
In Africa, if you're going to move
food from smallholder farmers
to roadside stall holders,
you need to have your own trucks.
You need to have your own warehouses.
You need to have your own tech stack and
you have control of the end to
end delivery in the supply chain.
That costs a significant amount of money,
even in a place like Africa, and
requires a level of competence that you
don't need to develop in Europe or the US.
And so, what are the quid pro quos?
Well, in Africa,
building a business that's 20 $30 million
of revenue in a particular sector,
particularly in certain geographies
makes you unique today.
In China, if you set up
a business on a Saturday doing x,
chances are if it's even
remotely successful on Monday,
by the following Saturday,
you'll have 30 competitors, right?
You can get better margins.
You can become profitable more quickly.
And even though using more capital
to quote, reinvent, the wheel and
certain elements, you're able to make
money out of those assets in a way
that you're not able to in other markets.
It's made more complicated because
we haven't seen exits repeatedly.
And so not many companies have been
sold and one or two have gone public and
that's pretty much it.
And so people are taking a leap of faith,
if I put the money in and
even if the business scales and
it's profitable,
how do I know I'm going to
get the money out?
That is a bet that they
need to make still, and
a bet they would make in any
emerging geography, by the way.
They'd have to do that in Southeast Asia
20 years ago or 15 years ago,
you don't now.
So people look at the pattern
recognition that didn't exist
in India 20 years ago,
but look, now it exists.
[MUSIC]
>> You describe the complexity
of the operating environment and
a lot of these countries in Africa and
why it might make sense to
build a warehouse because
you can't rent everything.
Does that create an incentive for
international companies to try to expand
their footprint through acquisition so
that They can find someone who understands
how to navigate all of that complexity and
they don't have to do it themselves in
a sense that they're buying the answer to
the complexity problem and thereby
they get access to 200 million people.
>> Exactly, and that's the thesis for
getting eventual exits,
is that there's going to be a small number
of companies that are now growing quickly.
That will graduate to a point where
they cover enough of the continent, so
they understand how to be
an African platform business.
That's number one, two they've
solved these kind of problems and
keep them under the hood if you will.
Right.
They know how to do it, and it's not a
problem day in and day out their business.
And then they know how to operate within
different regulatory regimes where that's
appropriate.
And therefore, a large company
doesn't have to do all that work and
take all that time to try and
scale on the continent.
So that is the payoff.
And that's the bet.
That investors are making at the moment.
The market is 95% plus fundraising, and
a very small proportion M&A,
10 years from now that will change but
at the moment companies are just
in the process of getting built to
a point where they have
the profile you're talking about.
But there are 1.2 billion people in
Africa and however little many of them
have in terms of daily income,
it is rising, so it's only question time.
[MUSIC]
>> I agree and I actually think that
the growth curve may be steeper, as well.
All the trends might be accelerating
even faster than they did.
For example, in India,
what I'm hearing more and
more from these founders,
is in their mind, somewhere in the future.
They would like to be acquired through
some kind of strategic partnership
that would enable them to grow and
be part of a bigger company.
So I want you to help me
address those people.
They've got a startup they found
secured some venture capital,
they see a strong growth path.
When in their mind, should they be
considering selling their business?
What are the triggers?
>> You don't really choose your moment,
at least for the best or better exits.
The moment chooses you and there's
a saying about being bought not sold and
the best exits are companies
that are bought not sold.
And what I mean is somebody
will quote come along and
pay strategic price because they
have a strategic imperative.
They want to expand in this or that area.
They want to do a deal to do this and
so they find the best available company
to do it and
they oftentimes will pay up for that.
The dirty little secret is that being
bought not sold takes an awful lot of
selling beforehand.
It's just not cold selling and I've talked
about this a few times in the past.
So what does it mean?
It means visibility in all
of the different stripes.
So one of the things that
tech-enabled businesses don't do is
spend very much on What I would
call corporate marketing.
In Africa, it's zero.
So, you're expecting somebody to do
all the work to work out that you're
actually a reasonable sized business
that I should be thinking about buying
when my strategic requirements dictate.
Of course,
you can always go do a search for
companies but, people buy people they
know for people they've heard of, and
there's a degree of comfort and
confidence with that.
The second which is deeper and
more relevant is building
those kinds of strategic relationships,
commercial awareness, etc.
Again, developing relationships with
companies that are likely buyers years
ahead.
Of when they actually might buy because a,
you as the CEO of
that company have no idea when
they're going to want to buy and
you might or might not have an idea
why they would want to buy.
And the other thing is,
there will be two or three or
four other companies that also would
make sense to buy at any point in time.
And so you are competing, and
you better think about that now i.e.,
well ahead of when you think
the exit window would open,
because you can't control events,
most of the best exits we've
worked on our quote surprises.
>> So let's dig into that a little bit.
I love the point about visibility,
basically visibility equals value.
So, spending on corporate
marketing is not just an expense,
it's actually an investment, should
be viewed as an investment and then.
On the business development side,
try to make deals with bigger companies.
So you can put yourself out there for
them to see you may not be able to see
under their hood, but you'd like them
to be able to see what's going on under
the hood in your business, right?
>> Well, I'll tell you what we
were doing so far this year,
right on preparation work.
We do a lot of prep work with companies
a year two years plus even before
they would look at doing an exit, so
one of the things we twice actually,
we've written year end press releases for
companies.
Now private company doesn't have to
release any information, but proactively,
we thought it was a good idea for
both these companies to start getting in
the practice of publishing the kind of
during Q1, how did we do last year?
Now it's not broadcasting numbers
because aren't that many numbers, but
it's broadcasting the messages
around why the company's attractive.
So it's almost like Pitch Deck and
the key points that you would want
to land with potential buyers.
For example,
from an African point of view,
we are going to expand into Ghana and
Senegal.
People always look at the disadvantages
that companies and frontier markets have.
So one of the things that a lot
of companies should do is look at
the advantages.
So the Wall Street Journal,
the Financial Times would follow all over
themselves to write an ESG driven story
about us purpose driven business.
That is scaling and an incredibly
hard market and beating the odds.
I mean, that story writes itself.
And if you were a $20 million
SaaS business in Denmark.
No disrespect to Denmark, nobody would
give you the time of day they don't care.
Right?
You're a $20 million company doing,
supply chain optimization or
whatever in West Africa.
I mean, you will have CNN, as an audience
for that you have an opportunity,
particularly with a wave
of interest in ESG.
To land visibility blows left, right and
center in a way that is deeply unfair.
>> [LAUGH] I get that and
it's not just a visibility.
I mean, it's another point I've heard
you make before is that you want to
demonstrate your authority over the topic,
right?
So you don't just write
about your product.
You write about your industry,
you write about your region you write some
because buyers are interested in expertise
and you need to get on their
radar screen as a viable expert.
>> It's all about the perception of
safety and effectively risk reduction.
If I've got senior team, as expressed
by the CEO that really understands
their market, and being authoritative,
and thought leadership, and all of that,
really is just an expression of you
we really understand our market.
This goes back to the point
you said earlier, which is,
a buyer will pay the most for
a company that sort of crack the code.
I've had to operate, so the more
thoughtful you are about market trends
that are really directly relevant to
you put them in a bigger picture.
The more that comes across without
you ever having to say, hey,
we know the market, you're just
showing people that you know it.
And again,
there's a huge unfair advantage.
Going back to my point before that
people companies have in African and
Middle East,
there's almost no market research.
You can have your own expression
definition of the market.
And frankly, that if you want
a huge body blow for visibility,
I mean, that is a nobody in
any other part of the world.
Would ever be able to do their
own primary market research and
get it out there, except in Africa.
So there's huge opportunities, which
is a quid pro quo for all the friction.
[MUSIC]
>> Going back to your earlier point, which
is companies don't really particularly in
these emerging markets are not
really preparing to sell, but
they should be prepared to be bought.
What things should I be thinking about
as a founder or CEO to make my company
attractive in the long run when
somebody starts to look under the hood.
>> If I'm a large company
doing an acquisition,
one of the things I want is a really
sturdy and deeper management team.
So I'm going to have a premium in
my mind for second line management.
Below the top two or three people,
and I want to know that those
people are also able to scale.
And in Africa, there's, as I said,
a huge dearth of that contrary.
So at an early stage, companies have
the opportunity to create their own
kind of talent academy internally.
So growing your own, but being able to
show a buyer that you've got a full house.
And when you're gone, there's three
other people who want your job.
That is incredibly
distinctive hard to do but
creates a degree of
resilience immediately.
So that kind of thing goes
an enormous way towards converting
the buyer because it takes away the risk.
[MUSIC]
>> So, to sum it up you may be
undervaluing the human capital
assets in your business.
>> That's right,
a second thing that companies worry about
from a buyer point of view is,
is it an African platform or not?
That's different for different sectors.
What is good enough
international expansion, but
the valuation is 50% higher.
If you're an African platform, maybe
even 100% in some cases, versus the same
amount of revenue that is regionally
locked in one or two markets only.
We're actually working on a deal now
which is sort of somewhere between
an acquisition and a merger
companies in two markets in Africa.
And one of the main drivers for
this is for
them to be able to operate under
regulation in both areas, right?
Rather than setting up in a new market and
going through all of that.
They want to do an acquisition in order
to be able to show immediately that they
are a Pan African business
despite the regulation.
And they think that should increase
their price per share almost overnight
pretty significantly.
And everybody looks for one plus one
equals more than two being able to
do that is one very clear
expression of that.
>> I'd like to pivot to some sort
of more basic practical type advice
from you just to help our listeners
understand a typical M&A process.
And so like what are the typical
steps in the process?
>> So at its heart, it's a deal so the two
elements of it are obviously finding or
engaging a buyer who's serious and
then closing it.
There are two very distinct parts to
the process getting a buyer on the hook.
If I could put it that way, there
are many ways of going about doing it.
As I said,
if one wants to be bought not sold and
really what that means is
you want the phone to ring.
So there are a million things that go into
the phone ringing confidence that you've
built relationships with people,
you've encouraged a commercial deal.
You've informed their
own strategic thinking.
We've had a client who wrote a deck, we
encourage them to send it in PowerPoint,
not PDF.
So that the buyer could lift by the way,
it was in the buyers colors,
buyer could copy and
paste a bunch of the graphics for
their own internal presentation
of what would make sense to do.
There's a lot of guidance informing, etc.
When a buyer comes to the table
decide to do something.
[MUSIC]
>> So
I got the phone call the first phone call.
What do I do next, right?
I've been setting myself up,
I put myself out there,
I've invested a corporate marketing.
I'm a recognized thought leader,
I have some important sub contracts,
showing traction.
I get the call, what do I need to know
about this person who's calling me?
How do I vet this potential buyer?
>> Well, it starts with what do you say?
What does a buyer want to hear?
On the one hand,
they want to hear that you're open, but
they don't expect to
hear any more than that.
So the answer usually is,
something we've been thinking about.
We've had on the radar screen our
investors, have been involved for
x period of time, we're open to talking.
It's not something that
we are planning to do.
You want to sometimes give a little bit of
a feel of exclusivity to the sense of like
we're not really going to
shop the company.
Probably we're only going to do
a deal with somebody we know and
actually your timing may not be bad.
And what a buyers really worried about is
that the CEO in particular has invested so
much of his or her time in blood.
And guts in the business
that they couldn't,
they just don't couldn't
imagine selling it to somebody.
And a lot of deals, never got off
the ground because the buyer has a feeling
that they're pushing water up hill.
>> I don't want to lose that point where
the person who gets the call maybe
actually really isn't emotionally
ready to sell their business.
>> You always behave as if you're open
even if you're not emotionally ready.
You need to be a grown
up to run a company.
up on these phone calls.
You know the person calling has
got a strategy behind their call,
has got money behind their call.
And you also don't know
what they're going to do.
I mean, they may be saying,
well do I acquire or
do I actually invest to go in this market?
There's a lot of things you don't know,
and it would be the height of arrogance,
that there's not a call
I really want to have.
If you're the CEO of a business
that's got traction,
part of your job description
is workout an exit.
That's your job.
So, it's as simple as do
that part of your job.
[MUSIC]
>> So what questions should the founder
be asking themselves in their quiet
dialogue with themselves to understand
whether they are mentally ready.
>> So
they're usually their own worst enemy.
And especially when you have
ecosystems like in Africa,
where hardly anybody's ever done, an exit.
The playbook isn't been written, and
you don't know anybody who's done this so
it's not like a valley where
you can call five people.
And hey how does this all work, your first
job is to work out a, are they for real?
B, is it something that I
should spend time on now?
This is an example of where emotion and
reaction in a vacuum,
because it is a vacuum as an early
ecosystem, really can create a distortion.
>> Let's go to that point,
so I got the call.
There's no playbook online for my market.
Where do I go for help?
Who do I talk to?
Where do I get, what resources do I,
yeah, I can't afford Victor Boston.
Who do I call?
>> You're touching a nerve a little
bit because this is really just
where the embryonic nature of
an ecosystem really, really bites,
right, in moments like this.
if you're the CEO, you have to be cautious
with who you talk to in your entire orbit.
Ordinarily, you'd bring your two or
three direct reports into the know,
relatively early on.
And you'd kind of consult with them and
they would give you their view, and
you want to make sure that it's good for
employees.
I don't want to over exaggerate this,
but you do need to be careful.
So that's a really lonely place to be.
What's going to end up happening is that
the CEO, he or she needs to fly solo,
for probably much longer than they
would do in a developed market.
[MUSIC]
>> Let's talk a little bit about
what happens as we close this deal.
I'm the founder CEO,
my firm is being acquired.
How should I think about my
role in this combined firm?
What are some of the different
arrangements you've seen?
>> So as a general rule,
large buyers want to legislate to
keep the CEO much longer than they
end up needing him or her for.
>> Why is that?
It's just a safety, derisk, he or
she has led this company and
we want them to lead a business unit.
And we want everybody in place.
And by the way, if that person stays,
we know that the other 30
people are going to stay.
So we want the CEO to sign a three
year employment agreement or
lockup or
whatever you want to call it, right?
We want to put some of the money
they're going to get frankly
at risk based on them
staying in the business.
More than 50% of the time, they all
realize after a year or a year and a half,
business has moved on,
we got our arms around it.
By the way,
you're really an entrepreneur at heart.
I don't know if this business
unit thing is really for you,
>> They accelerate it, and
they buy them out.
Yeah, buy them out or terminate early,
or maybe change their role into some
other role because sometimes there's
a bigger opportunity for them to be able
to graduate to which is all fine, but far
less often than CEOs think is the case.
Their role changes materially within
a couple of years of a deal, but
the legislation at the time
you do the deal is for
everything to be hardwired
exactly the same.
As far as the second line people,
normally, there is more opportunity
normally for those people than
the company would ever have standalone.
I know it sounds a little
counter intuitive.
But when you're looking at strategic
buyers coming into frontier Geography like
Africa, very few have got a big footprint
that you need to fold the company into.
This is not about smashing this with that,
they're trying to build around it.
They're trying to buy
Africa in many cases.
Therefore, for the second line
person who's in their thirties and
wants to be a CEO, you're just
going to get another huge addition
to the resources you have to play with.
And by the way,
somebody who's made a commitment,
paid a lot of money,
to actually go win in Africa.
So instead of being a startup
growth company, whatever,
you're now seriously incumbent.
Now, you may not want to do that forever
and want to start your own business.
But my God, if you can do five,
seven years of that and really build it to
scale, you can write your ticket anywhere
on the continent with any company.
So that opportunity for
second line managers can really open up.
>> What are some of the common mistakes
the CEOs make on the sell side
in the M&A process.
>> Not rehearsing their full team,
number one.
There was a deal we worked
on a few years ago.
The buyer came in to do due diligence,
a day was on technical due diligence.
They went through the whole day and
were perfectly satisfied.
The CTO turns to the buyer and says,
I don't know why you bothered asking all
these questions, you really should
have asked about blank, oops.
Needless to say, technical due
diligence took weeks and weeks.
And I think it turned out,
if I remember right,
it was an open source licensing issue or
something like that.
I can't remember what it was,
but you get the idea.
So we rehearse and
rehearse the senior team on message.
So when you're doing due diligence,
which is after you've agreed
the terms of the deal and
you're now trying to close it, right?
The guidances, value can shift 20,
25% easily from
what you thought you agreed,
and people don't realize,
think due diligence is just checking
stuff and then we're going to close.
Value shifts in all sorts of ways.
>> So Victor, at the end of the sales
process, what does success look like?
>> Success is having made only
small compromises late in the day.
Now, it's a kind of high level thing,
but you end up giving stuff away.
Your maximum point of leverage when you're
selling a business is of the time you're
agreeing the deal, right?
At that point, your leverage begins
to wane away, until a week or
two before the deal closes when you
have the least leverage possible.
Success is that you live to fight
another day, you make small compromises.
Actually what I try and
do is plan ahead for
compromises that seem bigger
than they really are.
So one big thing is around
the point we talked about before,
which is management retention and
packages, right?
If you can get a buyer
a little more comfortable,
change things around a little bit so
that, that part is really solid,
they might forget the $20 million they
want to take off of the price here.
>> And you as the founder, have to
understand what's your zone of agreement?
What are you actually willing to give up?
>> Yeah, and
also you go a little further even.
What you do is,
you then in the process of due diligence,
you are already listening to
what the buyer is saying.
And you get to understand what
really is important to the buyer.
And so if you're already preparing two or
three or
four of these gives late in the process,
you want to design them.
So they're of most value to the buyer,
but it's based on listening to them.
>> What do you wish I'd asked you,
what should I have asked
you that I haven't asked?
>> Why on earth would anybody start
a growth company in a place like Africa.
The thing is, it's not as simple
as making a difference or
having an impact or whatever,
I think it's more nuanced than that.
We all in our lives look for
opportunities where we can really
get a multiplier on our own time and
the value of our own time.
And in a geography like the African
continent, the multiplier of value,
multiplication on your own time
of entrepreneurial effort,
you cannot get a greater multiplier
anywhere in the world today.
The reality is that there's so
few companies doing it at scale.
There's so much to be done.
It isn't talked about,
even from species point of view
frankly could move the needle.
This is not about, well,
I want to feel good or give back or
make the world a better place,
nothing against any of that, right?
But you through the sheer
effort that these CEOs and
senior teams make in these geographies.
They get such a higher multiplier on
the value of their time than anybody
ever could anywhere else on earth.
Why wouldn't you?
>> Thank you Victor for guiding our
listeners through some of the best
practices in the acquisition process,
but especially for your optimism and
commitment to economic
prosperity on the continent.
This has been a masterclass from Grit &
Growth with Stanford Graduate School of
Business, and I'm your host,
Darrius Teeter.
In an upcoming episode, we will hear from
Matt Abrahams, a lecturer at Stanford,
and the host of the popular podcast,
Think Fast, Talk Smart.
Matt will guide us through
an interactive workshop,
to help entrepreneurs refine
their fundraising pitches.
I hope you'll join us.
[MUSIC]
If you want to find out more about how
Stanford Graduate School of Business is
partnering with entrepreneurs
throughout Africa and
South Asia through Stanford seed,
visit us@seed.stanford.edu/podcast.
If you liked this episode, don't forget
to hit follow and share it with a friend.
Grit and Growth is a podcast by Stanford
Seed, Laurie Fuller researched and
developed content for this episode with
additional research by Jeff Prickett.
Kendrick Gleditsch,
she's our production coordinator, and
our executive producer is Tiffany Steeps.
With writing and production from
Isabel Polaroid and Andrew Ganim.
And sound design and mixing by
Alex Bennett at Lower Street Media.
Thanks for joining us.
We'll see you next time.
[MUSIC]